[Music]
hey everyone its Peter Brown standing in
for freelance reviewer Jason to April
for his review of next machina next
machina is a modern revamp of Robotron
2084 in all but name and developer
housemarque even managed to collaborate
with Robotron x' creator eugene jarvis
to bring the high-quality homage to life
conceptually the two games are nearly
identical and every aspect of next
machina is appropriately chock-full of
nostalgia the gorgeously trippy graphics
feel simultaneously modern and retro and
the synth Wave soundtrack complements
the sci-fi action perfectly
[Music]
in the same vein as pac-man Championship
Edition next machina is one of the best
modernisations of a classic arcade game
that you can find its plot is brief and
to the point you're a lone hero trying
to save what remains of humanity during
a robot apocalypse the twin-stick
shooting action that defines your fight
is tight and responsive and every world
is relentlessly challenging individual
levels are small fast paced and
frequently packed with secrets to
discover MIT's the chaotic hero on robot
action and death comes instantly whether
you get hit by a lone bullet or simply
bump into a nearby enemy next machina is
pronounced difficulty is by design
harkening back to the challenge of its
arcade source material beyond advancing
through stages skillful play is rewarded
through item upgrades bonus points and a
strong sense of satisfaction from
overcoming seemingly impossible odds
next machina is hard but is also
thoroughly gratifying
[Applause]
world complete your primary objective in
each level is to destroy a number of
enemy waves before rocketing off to the
next set piece there are however
numerous secondary objectives to
consider along the way as with Robotron
there are a handful of humans haplessly
wandering around each stage rescuing
them just by touching them requires
precise timing as you must not only
protect your own hide but also defeat
enemies who are whittling away the
wandering humans health saving humans is
considered optional but it's a
relentlessly tempting and risky
distraction that you'll chase time and
time again even when you should know
better
[Music]
boss battles at the end of each world
are the biggest test throwing out dense
curtains of bullets that demand exacting
movements to avoid all are challenging
and each is drastically different from a
mechanical ape that sits atop of the
screen and throws flaming debris at you
- a giant Terminator like skull and a
hive mind boss that attacks from the
safety of a protective field adding to
the challenge boss fights follow a
series of dense enemy waves and if you
lose all your lives and end up using a
continue you have to start the process
all over again
[Music]
now you can point to dense waves of
enemies and monstrous bosses as the
reasons next machina is so hard but more
than their numbers our size is the range
of tactics enemies employ that
ultimately stress you out some
mindlessly plow toward you others will
make bee lines to humans and there are
burrowing turrets that send out waves of
exploding balls among a variety of other
robotic dangers you typically face
myriad enemy types all at once from all
directions creating a juggling act that
would be impossible to contend with if
not for your special abilities dashing
is central to surviving in next machina
harsh world as it was in-house marks
previous games resogun in Super Stardust
once activated you're invulnerable for
the duration of the lunch and your
timing has to be perfect given the small
margin for error in most levels misjudge
the duration of your - through a crowd
by a nanosecond and you'll lose a life
since there's a brief recharge period
between dashes you can't abuse it by
default either this is alleviated
somewhat if you spot and grab a triple
dash powerup but these are few and far
between and don't completely diminish
the risk of an untimely sprint in the
wrong direction
secondary weapons however are more
prevalent and can make or break you
depending on the scenario your options
include powerful lasers rockets floating
bombs or a sword for deadly close up
attacks these also require a brief pause
to recharge which reinforces the idea
that your ability to manage cooldown
meters is a critical skill and another
important layer to track during frantic
on slots you can in theory play through
next machina in under an hour
but it's eminently replayable thanks to
the number of Secrets waiting to be
found and the skills you need to hone in
order to survive and climb to the top of
the leaderboards you do have the option
of bringing a friend along but next
mocking is multiplayer is woefully
limited to local engagement zone a lack
of online play is a notable
disappointment next machina is a game
that confidently meets expectations it's
difficult intensely satisfying and
packed with enough secrets and lofty
secondary objectives to keep you and
raptured for hours
it's a classic game at heart but with
refined challenges and exacting
mechanics it feels right at home in the
modern era
[Music]